six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's try a different number if we can
let's go these are always fun let's go
to country code 33
who's calling from country code 33 and
who's this Jason Jason where you calling
from I'm calling from France but I'm a
San Diego and in fact beautiful but
we're in France are you lose you lose
wow that is that what's that like what's
living in Toulouse like boy I came here
because of my wife and now I'm here
because of my job and sadly I don't
think watching YouTube every night
combination in your channel and a few
others I don't think I'm ready to go
back anytime soon that's for sure I
don't blame you what's your question
today well my question is what do you I
mean I saw Hillary Clinton was in the
news again today when she broke her hand
she causes me a whole lot of heartbreak
because honestly I was not able to vote
for her last year who were you able to
vote for I wasn't I mean for me it's an
absentee ballot right and uh I'm
registered to vote and my wife was
adamant that I vote for Hillary and of
course coming from California I knew it
really didn't matter right but I
understand a lot of what happened but
who did you vote for ultimately I did
not vote but I really see her as a big
part of the problem yeah and every time
I see her name in the news I just
completely upsets me because I think
that she should just go away okay um and
I was curious how you feel about I mean
honestly yeah I don't like the word
deplorable I don't like the word
snowflake I don't like what's going on
in my country but I really don't I don't
see how the Democratic Party could have
put her forward first of all and I just
don't know that I trust them to put
somebody good forward next time
well yeah you should write about they've
not earned our trust I think that you're
right as far as that goes now correct me
if I'm wrong wasn't Hillary in the news
this week because she sprained her ankle
or something that's not the article that
I saw the article I saw was more boy
commented on how that she won the the
states that had the most economic impact
in the United States and then the states
that voted for Trump were of course
these least interesting economically and
it was more about her still trying to
explain why she lost the election yeah
well listen I think nobody coverage of
Hillary Clinton because she is a notable
politician I think the more interesting
part of your commentary is can we trust
the DNC in 2020 and I am skeptical that
we can I I have seen they have lost my
trust and certainly have not regained it
so I share your skepticism there yeah I
mean if you stay on YouTube you see a
lot of support for Bernie Sanders you
see a lot of support for the underdog so
to speak yeah but listen case your
system is don't you and yet when you
move to France how old were you it was
about 15 years old
so I'm now interesting yeah because I
feel like there's no just a very very
slight hint of a French accent in your
English which is fascinating because
like when I moved to the u.s. in English
I don't have a noticeable accent but now
when I speak Spanish I do and it's just
interesting how that how that happens
when one moves you know oh yeah I work
in biological research so a lot of our
work is done in English but of course
I'm living in France my kids are in a
bilingual school alright Jason very good
I really appreciate the call and share
your skepticism about the DNC running a
fair primary and if it's not fair about
running an unfair primary where they
choose the right person I share your
skepticism